former British ambassador to Russia
should we uh so Tony Brenton hello to
you sir Tony it's good to see you again
thank you for joining us on the program
this morning
um first of all should we just start
with the latest situation uh in the
donbass region it does look as though I
mean initially when the war first broke
out we thought this was the region that
Russia would be most interested in they
had a scattergun approach but now
consolidating in that area how surprised
are you
yeah no I'm not surprised this has been
pretty clearly coming for a few weeks as
the Russians have been after failing in
their initial assaults on Kiev have been
reorganizing to go precisely for the Don
Bass the donbass is the logical place
for them to go for one of the claims
they've made in launching the war was to
protect the population of the donbass
from what they described as Ukrainian
genocide
I'm sorry
that's okay as long as it's not
President Putin we can wait no no okay
I've killed it
um they've so this was predictable it is
now launched and it is as your
correspondent Deborah I think said
probably we're not the decisive phase of
the war because one of two things can
happen either they succeed in in the
donbass and take that region in which
case they've got a huge negotiating
um ploy
um they've got a huge negotiating ploy
to use with the um the opinions in any
in any discussions that might then take
place or there is a danger that Putin
May revive his earlier ambition of going
again for Kiev and going for the whole
of Ukraine in effect
the alternative and I suspect more
likely um of course is that this thing
is going to get bogged down as their
previous offensive gets bogged down
you're in for a quite long War of
Attrition between the two sides at which
point both sides at some point will
begin looking for a negotiated outcome
but we'll have to see a lot now it
depends immensely on how the military
campaign goes yeah has it not been
proven or have we not seen that Ukraine
Ukrainian Fighters are more than what
President Putin was expecting they have
suffered heavy defeats both with their
Armory and indeed with their military
personnel as well and trying to take
over the whole of Ukraine is not
feasible
well it was not feasible in the original
approach which was to send their troops
in every every possible Direction
whether it is feasible to take the
donbass and then proceed from there
remains to be seen as I say I think the
likelihood is not and yes we all got it
wrong initially the chief of the US
general staff said at the very beginning
that the Russians were likely to be able
to take care of in 72 hours so lots of
military experts have got egg on their
face about the incapacity of the
Russians to win the war as they
initially fought it the big question is
whether they've they've resolved the the
incompetence that they showed the first
time around they found themselves as you
said up against a much more effective
and cohesive and high morale Ukrainian
Armed Forces than they expected and also
a Ukrainian Armed Force which has been
massively armed and the UK has a lot to
do with this by the West which has made
a very big difference their ability to
uh to to advance
talk to me about I mean we said that you
were um the ambassador to Russia uh in I
think 2004 to 2008 I think that's right
insane Mr Ambassador I'm sure you must
have met Putin in that time
um what sort of man
how do you remember him and how do you
think he'll be dealing with what's
happening in Ukraine at the moment
well how I remember him is this is a
very able focused not very nice
um leader of Russia driven by the desire
to make Russia Great again to coin a
phrase uh and a man who took risks but
calculated rather carefully before
ticking them very clearly the the Putin
we're dealing with now is in some
significant ways different that he has
launched this he's taken this huge risk
of this War I think
he's been brooding over his isolation
through in covid about Ukraine which is
he's essential to making Russia Great
again and has launched this war which it
looks very unlikely that it could win he
can win on the terms that he originally
set for himself so he's disappointed I
suspect he's angry he's talked a couple
of times about going nuclear which would
be a very big threshold to cross if he
went for it but I wouldn't rule it out
entirely if things go very badly wrong
for him so I suspect that what we need
to be doing is persuading if not him
personally then the people around him
that there is a a respectable way out of
this for Russia and which preserves
Ukraine and we need to be edging our way
towards that so does the West have to
give him from what you're saying some
sort of get out of get out clause so
that he won't use potentially nuclear
weapons is that what you're saying let
me give you a little bit of history back
in 1962 President John F Kennedy dealing
with the Cuban Missile Crisis said that
while the United States absolutely must
not do is confront a nuclear-armed
adversary by which he meant the Soviet
Union at the time with the choice
between total humiliation and nuclear
escalation that remains as true today as
it was when he said it yes the Russians
have behaved appallingly yes the
political
um feel of dealing with a country which
has committed so many atrocities and so
many illegalities is going to be very
hard but if the alternative is to move
across a nuclear threshold then we're
going to have to bite our tongues a bit
and do it
in the meantime what about these two
British Fighters as far as the British
government is concerned via the Northern
Ireland secretary this morning you know
they're they're there illegally
um and it just sounded so they're on
their own for now Russia wants to do a
deal a a prisoner swap deal if you will
with a with a Ukrainian uh uh MP former
leader of the opposition in Ukraine
um what do you think Putin will do about
these two
I think he probably sees him as
negotiating material for use with us we
in Putin's eyes are among the most
um rabbit of the West's opponents to
Russia
um they are useful for discussions as
part of what eventually we all hope will
be a be a peace negotiation what we
there are some things we obviously need
to be doing we need to be seeking
Consular access to them to make sure
they're being treated decently we need
to make it short we need to make it
clear to Putin that indeed their fate
will form part of whatever negotiation
we eventually end up in and if they are
maltreated then that will form part of
our attitude in those negotiations but
in terms of getting them out quickly
barring a real change of mood on the
part of the Russians I don't think that
that's very likely to happen
okay so Tony um fascinating stuff I'll
let you get back to your phone call
thank you very much indeed for joining
sorry about that you appreciate it not
at all thank you for joining us all
right